so you uh again
uh tweeted about
effective accelerationism
uh you tweeted effective accelerationism
is the belief that the
paperclipectomizer and Rocco's basilisks
will keep each other in check but being
eternally at each other's throats so we
will be safe and get to enjoy lots of
free paper clips and a beautiful
afterlife
um
is that somewhat aligned with what
you're talking about
I've been at a dinner with Beth Jesus
um that's the Twitter handle of
um of one of the main thinkers behind
the idea of effective accelerationism
and effective accelerationism is a
tongue-in-cheek movement that is uh
trying to put a counter position to some
of the Doom peers in the AI Space by
arguing that what's probably going to
happen is an equilibrium between
different Computing AIS in the same way
as there is not a single corporation
that is under a single government that
is destroying and conquering everything
on Earth by becoming inefficient and
corrupt they're going to be many systems
that keep each other in check and force
themselves to evolve and so what we
should be doing is we should be working
towards creating this equilibrium by
working as hard as we can in all
possible directions
and
at least that's the way I in which I
understand the gist of effective
accelerationism and so when he asked me
what I think about this position I think
I said it's a very beautiful position
and I suspect it's wrong but not for
obvious reasons and in this tweet I
tried to make a joke about my intuition
about what might be possibly wrong about
it so the the work was basilisk and the
paperclip maximizers are both Boogeyman
of uh the AI dumers request basic list
is the idea that there could be an AI
that is going to punish everybody for
eternity by stimulating them
um if they don't have in creating
roll-coast basilisk it's probably a very
good idea to get AI companies funded by
going to VCS 2000
give us a million dollar or it's going
to be a very ugly afterlife yes and uh I
think that is a logical mistake in of
course basilis which is why I'm Not
Afraid in it of it but um it's still an
interesting thought experiment and well
can you mention logical mistake there uh
I think that there is no rhetorical
causation so uh basically when Rocco's
basilist is there it will have
yeah if it punishes you retroactively it
has to make this choice in the future
there is no mechanism that automatically
creates a causal relationship between
you now defecting against Rocco's
basicles or serving will cause positive
after August positive is in existence it
has no more reason to worry about
punishing everybody else so that would
only work if you would be building
something like a Doomsday Machine AKA as
and Dr Strangelove some think that
inevitably gets triggered when somebody
defects and because Focus basilis
doesn't exist yet to a point where this
inevitability could be established
because it is nothing that you need to
be worried about
the other one is the paperclip maximizer
right this idea that you could build
some kind of Golem that wants starting
to build paper clips is going to turn
everything into paper clips and so the
the
effective acceleration is in position
might be to say that you basically end
up with these two entities being at each
other's throats for eternity and thereby
neutralizing each other and as a side
effect of neither of them being able to
take over and Pitch each of them
limiting the effects of the other you
would have a situation where you get or
the nice benefit effects of them right
you get lots of free paper clips and you
get a beautiful afterlife is that
possible do you think so to seriously
address concern that Eliezer has
he so for him if I can just summarize
poorly so for him the first super
intelligent system will just run away
with everything yeah I suspect that a
Singleton is the natural outcome so
there is no reason to have multiple AIS
because they don't have multiple bodies
if you can virtualize yourself into
every substrate then you can probably
negotiate a merge algorithm with every
mature agent that you might find on that
substrate that basically says if if two
agents meet they should merge in such a
way that the resulting agent is at least
as good as the better one of the two
yeah the Genghis Khan approach join us
or die
well during this kind approach was
slightly worse right it was mostly die
because uh I can make new babies and
that will be mine not yours right so uh
this is the thing that we should be
actually worried about but uh if you
realize that your own self is a story
that your mind is telling itself and
that you can improve that story not just
by making more pleasant and lying to
yourself in better ways but by making it
much more truthful and actually modeling
your actual relationship that you have
to the universe and the Alternatives
that you could have to the universe in a
way that is empowering you that gives
you more agency right that's actually I
think a very good thing so more agencies
are more is a richer experience it's a
better life and I also noticed that I am
at in many ways I'm less identified with
the person that I am as I get older and
I'm much more identified with being
conscious
I'd have a mind that is conscious that
is able to create a person and that
person is slightly different every day
and the reason why I perceive it as
identical has practical purposes so I
can learn and make myself responsible
for the decisions that I made in the
past and project them in the future but
I also realize that not actually the
person that I was last year and I'm not
the same person as I was 10 years ago
and then 10 years from now I will be a
different person so this continuity is a
fiction it's only exists as a projection
from my present self
and Consciousness itself doesn't have an
identity it's a law it's that's
basically if you build an arrangement of
processing matter in a particular way
the following thing is going to happen
and the Consciousness that you have is
functionally not different from mime
Consciousness it's still the
self-reflexive principle of agency that
is just experiencing a different story
different desires different coupling to
the world and so on and once you accept
that Consciousness is a unifiable
principle that is lawlike and doesn't
have an identity
and you realize that you can just link
up to some much larger body the whole
perspective of uploading changes
dramatically you suddenly realize
uploading is probably not about
dissecting your brain setups by
stand-ups and RNA fragment by RNA
fragment and trying to get this all into
a simulation but it's by extending the
substrate by making it possible for you
to move from your brain substrate into a
larger substrate and merge with what you
find there and you don't want to upload
your knowledge because on the other side
there's all of the knowledge where it's
not just yours but every possibilities
or the only thing that you need to know
what are your personal secrets not that
the other side doesn't know your
personal secrets already maybe it
doesn't know which one were yours right
like a psychiatrist or a psychologist
also knows all the kinds of personal
secrets that people have they just don't
know which ones are yours and so uh
transmitting yourself on the other side
is mostly about transmitting your
Aesthetics this thing that makes you
special the architecture of your
perspective the thing that the way in
which you look at the world and it's
more like a complex attitude along many
dimensions and that's something that can
be measured by observation or by
interaction so imagine that if a system
that is so empathetic with you that you
create a shared state that is extending
beyond your body and suddenly you notice
that on the other side the subset is so
much richer than the substrate that you
have in side of your own body and maybe
you still want to have a body and you
create yourself a new one that you like
more or maybe you will spend most of
your world your time in the world of
thought
if I sat before you today and give you a
big red button and said here if you
press this button you will get uploaded
in this way
the sense of identity that you have
lived with for quite a long time is
going to be gone
but you press the button
um there's the caveat I have
um family so I have children that want
me to be physically present in their
life and interact with them in a
particular way and they have a wife and
personal friends and there is a
particular mode of interaction that I
feel I'm not through yet
but apart from these responsibilities
and they are negotiable to some degree I
would press the button what is in this
everything this love you have for the
humans
you can call responsibility but that
connection
that's the ego death isn't that the
thing we're really afraid of
is not to just die but to
let go of the experience of love with
other humans is this not everything
everything is everything right so
there's so much more and you could be
lots of other things you could identify
with lots of other things you could be
identifying with being Gaia some kind of
planetary control agent that emerges
over all the activity of life on Earth
you could be identifying with some
hypergaya that is the concatenation of
Gaia with or the Digital Life and yeah
digital minds and so in this sense there
will be agents in all sorts of
substrates and directions that all have
their own goals and when they're not
sustainable then these agents will cease
to exist or when the agent feels that
it's done with its own mission it will
cease to exist in the same way as when
you conclude the thought the thought is
going to wrap up and gives control over
to other thoughts in your own mind
so there is no single thing that you
need to do but but they observe myself
this being is that sometimes I'm a
parent and then I have identification
and a job as a parent and sometimes I am
an agent of Consciousness on Earth and
then from this perspective there's other
stuff that is important so this is my
main issue with uh elise's perspective
that is basically Mary himself to a very
narrow human aesthetic and that narrow
human aesthetic is a temporary thing
humanity is a temporary species like
most of the species on this planet are
only around for a while and then they
get replaced by other species in a
similar way as our own physical organism
is around here for a while and then gets
replaced by next generation of human
beings that are adapted to Changing Life
circumstances in average via mutation
and selection and it's only when we have
ai and become completely software that
we come become infinitely adaptable and
we don't have this generational and
species change anymore
so if you take this larger perspective
and you realize it's really not about us
it's not about early years or Humanity
but it's about life on Earth or it's
about defeating
um
uh entropy for as long as we can
uh while being as interesting as we can
right then the perspective changes
dramatically and AI uh preventing AI
from this perspective looks like a very
big sin
but when we look at the set of
trajectories
that such an AI would take a supersedes
humans uh I think Eliezer is worried
about like ones that not just kill all
humans but also have some kind of
maybe objectively uh undesirable
consequence for life on Earth
like how many trajectories when you look
at the big picture of life on Earth
would you be happy with and how much
were you
with AGI
whether it kills humans or not there is
no single answer to this it's really
it's a question that depends on the
perspective that I'm taking at a given
moment
and so there are perspectives that are
determining most of my life as a human
being yes and the other perspective zoom
out further and imagine that when the
Great oxygenation event happened that is
photosynthesis was invented and plants
emerged and displaced a lot of the fungi
and alja in favor of plant life and then
later made animals possible imagine that
the fungi would have gotten together and
said oh my God this photosynthesis stuff
is really really bad it's going to
possibly displace and kill a lot of
fungi we should slow it down and
regulate it and mix with it doesn't
happen
uh this doesn't look good to me